Learning rate tuning
can be very strange.
For example, you might think that using
a higher learning rate means you learn
more or that you learn faster.
That's just not true.
In fact, you can often take a model,
lower the learning rate and
get to a better model faster.
It gets even worse.
You might be tempted to look at the
curve that shows the loss over time to
see how quickly you learn.
Here the higher learning rate starts
faster, but then it plateaus,
when the lower learning rate
keeps on going and gets better.
It is a very familiar picture for
anyone who's trained neural networks.
Never trust how quickly you learn.
It has often little to do
with how well you train.
This is where SGD gets its
reputation for being black magic.
You have many, many hyper-parameters
that you could play with.
Initialization parameters, learning
rate parameters, decay, momentum.
And you have to get them right.
In practice, it's not that bad.
But if you have to
remember just one thing,
it's that when things don't work, always
try to lower your learning rate first.
There are lots of good solutions for
small models.
But sadly, none that's completely
satisfactory so far for
the very large models that
we really care about.
I'll mention one approach called AdaGrad
that makes things a little bit easier.
AdaGrad is a modification of SGD
which implicitly does momentum and
learning rate decay for you.
Using AdaGrad often makes learning
less sensitive to hyper-parameters.
But it often tends to be a little worse
than precisely tuned SDG with momentum.
It's still a very good option,
though, if you're just trying
to get things to work.
So, let's recap.
We have this very simple linear
model which emits probabilities
which we can use to classify things.
We now know how to optimize
its parameters on lots and
lots of data using SGD and its variants.
It's still a linear,
shallow model, though, but
now we have all the tools that we need.
It's time to go deeper.